happening now coming at you Wednesday
afternoon Lis say at Uncle Joey what's
happening Beau you for [__] people
what's going on with you [__] licker I
had a good night last night I [__]
tore my arm up but it's good I'm uh you
ask and everyone keeps asking me if I
likeed Jiu-Jitsu I'm not at the point
that I like it at all yet but it's been
uh it's been a lot of fun and something
happened that you told me would happen I
had a not an epiphany in the shower but
I was just thinking about it because we
were doing this stuff and it was
hysterical we were just doing it on the
floor right here but I I was doing it
with Casey last night and he's a blue
belt but he was showing me how when I'm
in half guard on the bottom how to like
sneak out like we were doing it where
like you kick your leg up and you just
shoot out and take the back right and I
kept it wasn't as smooth as it should be
as everyone else was doing it but he
showed me it's like you do one move and
you just get to your side and then you
do a whole another move and you get
there and it's something that you you
don't get mad at me about but sometimes
I think too far ahead I think a lot of
people do it is they they look at maybe
the big picture too much and and like
I've just noticed in Jiu-Jitsu so far
that it's just about doing very small
things in the right order so like I was
thinking it works the same way for your
whole life it's just you can't just get
a great podcast you can't just be a
comedian it's little small things and it
just like I was in the shower and I
almost called you from the shower I
don't know why it just hit me right
there there but it was crazy you know
hard work is hard work yeah
and yeah I was telling you that the
first four years for me for comedy were
just painful it was just painful it was
[__] brutal it was painful it was
something that uh you're broke cuz you
don't want to work cuz something over
your head says you can't work you know I
did little things to stay alive but I
wasn't making any money you know people
always say to me yeah you're making any
money from me it's not that you're
making any money it's that you love
doing what you doing when we go to
Jiu-Jitsu we pay a monthly fee to go
there and we go there to get tortured
but the more you go the easier it
becomes that's why I always say once you
stop going you got to start all over
again that's fear I'm a specialist and
fearly oh yeah because I've been scaring
myself [__] Vincent Price Vincent Price
could suck my dick I scare the [__] out
of myself because I would always look at
the
steps I would always think about Friday
and instead of Tuesday yeah and then you
[__] up the whole week cuz you're not
thinking about what's in front of you
you're always thinking about what's and
then you you C you cave you already say
no to it I'm just not going to go and
that's it and I did that for years Lee I
blew a thousand jobs I blew a thousand
careers by doing that by by looking at
in front and all I started saying that's
got nothing to do with it you know I was
thinking about Nick I love Nick with all
my heart but every time I used to call
Nick and go
nick uh My Name is Earl I never forget I
had a conversation with him I got a call
in Sacramento okay and they're like Joey
they're looking for convict looking
[__] for my name is
Z all right right I [__] canceled the
week like I was in Sacramento I did
Thursday night I was like I got to go I
was a feature act for Gabriel Gabriel
didn't talk to me for two years over
that and I [__] shot down to
La cuz I told him this is what I'm in La
for to whatever so to make the story
short I went in there and when I left I
knew I booked it and and the guy goes
I'm looking for four more guys so I went
home I called Nick I'm like Nick they
looking for Comic looking guys who's the
director what are they paying is it
recurring or is it a Ser you know there
was 19 questions before the [__]
thing just do it what's with the [__]
questions you're going to see that all
those questions are just uh not detours
but they're kind of detours distractions
distractions you know what the [__] with
the questions just do what the [__] they
ask of you go in there book the job and
then we'll worry about everything else
everything else will fall into place
we'll figure it out but people who like
well I didn't go because I'm you get
those people like I didn't go tonight
because I'm out of town for a month who
gives a [__] guess who was one of those
people leave me and I was going to
taekwondo and I stopped going cuz I was
on Blow I couldn't wait till 8:00 to go
to class I would go to class from 6:30
to 7:30 and I'd be scratching the whole
time in class all oh because all I
couldn't wait to get a package and it
was two doors down from Malcolm Padre
are you [__] kidding me are you
[__] kidding me and one day I bumped
into the guy and I was kind of hiding in
my car and he came over and knocked on
the glass his name is Chris nir he's a
Jiu-Jitsu guy now and he came over and
he goes can I talk to you for a second
he goes get out of the [__] car he
goes listen man it's a martial art it's
the same thing you're doing every night
on
stage the same thing it's all wrapped up
the same [__] way the more you come
come in the better you get at it right
you know and he goes even if you come in
and do it once a week just once a week
it's a lot better cuz that you know what
I would say well what am I going to come
in for on Monday if I'm going to leave
on Wednesday and not going to be able to
exercise right and he go what why
wouldn't you be and that's the guy who
said what in these hotels they don't
have gyms I wouldn't even look I would
go on the road with Eddie Tate and Joe
and they would say everybody meet at the
gym at 1:00 I wouldn't even look down
there I would be embarrassed to go to
the gym oh yeah of course I mean it's
it's kind of ridiculous when you make
EXC excuses like that like I I almost
didn't go last night I just I was
feeling kind of off from the podcast on
Monday I just didn't want to go and I
was like I was L I was already in my car
and I was like I could not go but how
would I explain this and then of course
as soon as I got there Zach texted me
the teacher so if I hadn't got I would
have had to make an excuse and I was
like yeah I didn't feel great and it
wasn't my best class but at least I went
you went listen listen man you keep
showing up you just keep showing up it's
amazing what happens when you keep
showing up you know I just keep showing
up to Jiu-Jitsu I'm the worst guy in the
[__] class but I keep showing up and
the same thing for comedy it's the same
thing I was horrible when I picked a
major I didn't do badly I could always
study and I always knew how to study
right I know that if you take notes in
class light notes light notes you can't
put your head in that [__] notebook
and write us a liqu it's a light note
about a
situation um you know we're talking
about podcasting or something you can't
sit there and write you know oh podcast
Lee says that p no little notes yellow
in you know what I'm saying like put a
note there uh stay fresh and put the
thing in there in yellow if you do that
and you go home every night and you
review that a little bit and you read
the chapter how the professor says just
how he says to do it and these chapters
aren't that long you could do it in two
days yeah okay you're pretty much good
come finals you don't have to cram And
if every week for 10 minutes you look
over that those pages and just read what
you wrote down you'll be Perfect the
final time if I had done that I would
have gone to Harvard yeah that that's it
that's the chemistry that's the
chemistry of so when I was taking all
those other classes at CMC at Colorado
Mountain College I was doing that I was
pretty good I was already a [__]
20year old so yeah I already was you
know Jesus Christ this is easy for me
now I could Master this
now excuse me and then when I got to uh
University of Colorado I had to pick a
major when they hit me with econ
Lee it just wasn't working it got real
it got real and I was [__] flunking
intro to macro or some [__] intro to
micro you know the little [__] not even
the when it becomes something big I was
like just gone and I was ready ready and
I went into a couns somebody said have
you considered a counselor what the [__]
is a counselor going to do when you're
stupid you're stupid and this [__]
dude muhamed zabib and me started
banging it out two hours a week and like
by the third or fourth week I lifted my
GPA I was up there again it Tes so for
some people it takes harder to get
something yeah but if you quit you're
not going to get it I'm against quitting
when I was a kid I quit so many [__]
things yeah just because oh maybe this
or a fear you know I have always said
thinking is either the best thing you
could do for a man or the worst thing
you could do for a man when you really
think of a situation you know yeah no I
I I get a lot of emails recently about
how did you make the decision to come
out to
LA and i' I've started thinking about I
really didn't even make the decision it
just kind of just I knew it was going to
happen so I I didn't even it's not like
I sat down and planned it out I just
like okay when I graduate I'm moving to
La so it's uh but it I'm slow with other
stuff like I'm still with the working
out and and doing other stuff like that
but it just it's weird how how similar
we all are but how different like
something like I would like the fact
that you get up on stage freaks me out
or the fact that you I don't know did
all those robberies which isn't
something like necessarily proud of but
it's just it's weird how different we
all are and we try to be try
to uh measure oursel against other
people when it really has no bearing at
all like because they did it you have to
do right right right right no I was the
king of that one you know and I got out
of that when I when I moved T I knew to
move forward as a comedian as a human
being I had to stop worrying about this
one was getting and why he was getting
it and being angry that really held me
back for a long time as a human being as
a comedian because that's your you grew
up with that people saying to you oh I
got invited to this place and here you
got invited to the [__] park for a
Halloween party or some [__] I used to
do it in school like I used to get
really upset when people got better
grades than I did or or but it's uh I
think that's why I'm not quitting I'm
cuz I'm never I'm never going to be good
at Jitsu but neither am I if I could be
neither but let's pretend you get good
at one move yeah that's what he can said
right let's pretend you find one
move that all that and even though the
person knows it's coming doesn't matter
because you're going to look for that
that's your one move you're going to
look for that one move that's your go-to
move all you need is one move in
Jiu-Jitsu maybe two moves on defense
Escape push away get your leg back and
you're back to square run you're going
for that same [__] move have you
found your move yet no I got no moves
really you don't have you don't have one
that you like I like Kamas okay yeah
that's what we learned yesterday kamor
yeah I like
um a bow and arrow choke okay I like
that one from the because I always end
up in that position with people so I
could go for a choke and your hands they
don't know what hands you're doing and
then you strap and you turn around real
quick and you grab their pants and pull
them up so I like that one I like the
straight arm bar not the one that Ronda
Rousey does I I've never even heard of
it before but just it's the same sort of
way that you do the Cur except you just
kind of
like block their arm and then push it
straight cuz I have short arms so for me
to get the cura to grab my own wrist I
couldn't do it couldn't do it so I was
like okay let's they said try the
straight arm BR I was like oh that's
cool I like that it's just uh
listen sticking with something is always
and I bro I let so I can't believe I
stuck with comedy I told you two weeks
ago we had a guest on something about
stand up it wasn't Brian's gallaro it
was two three weeks ago and we were
talking about the struggle here and we
got really high and in edible and I went
home and something uh my Roku wasn't
working sometimes I go to that Roku and
it's not working okay all the shows
aren't on it says maintenance or some
[__] for 10 minutes I don't [__]
know so I took a notebook on and I was
writing and for some reason I went back
to living in that basement in Boulder
and I had the most saddest [__]
existence it was worse than the rocky
apartment and and I forced myself every
night because I didn't even have
groceries in the refrigerator so I
forced myself every night to find the
spot when I went this is why I talk
about discipline you know you always
talk about you always hear about you
know this uh Chinese discipline or
Russian discipline when I went back I
was such bad shape emotionally I was so
heartbroken and so frustrated M I knew
as a human being not a [__]
psychiatric psychiatrist or nothing I
knew as a human
being that I couldn't stay in that house
at night like I went on the line I went
not on line I went on like a comedy
newspaper and in those days in Denver
legitimately in those days in Denver
legitimately in 19 in the in 1993 to
1995 on Monday nights you had an open
mic on an Australian bar that usually
had seven or eight people on Tuesdays
you had the Comedy Works and they put
you they give you three minutes every 3
weeks on Wednesday you had a a Commerce
thing like a truck stop okay Wednesday
you had the Elvis impersonator that we
spoke about talk about on this podcast I
think so yeah the guy that was an Elvis
impersonator and he he flunked and
[__] Vegas so he bought a bar and and
then Thursday night was El Torito oh wow
and Friday and Saturday you had nothing
and you had guest spots at different
places one Saturday a month on at 11:
there was a [__] room all the way in
Cherry Hill or whatever it's called in
Colorado it was like 50 minutes away
from where I lived and you went all the
way there nobody knew me so I always
went up last at [__] 115 were these
all open
mics all of them there was no money in
my life so you could you you could get
up at all
these I I knew that my mental situation
I was I was 31 years old I had no money
I had no savings I had a beat up car all
I had was the clothes I had in that
apartment I was freshly divorced I had a
cocaine habit and I had a heart of a
[__] criminal and I but I wanted to
do standup I didn't know standup was
going to save me I didn't know standup
was going to be take me here with you I
didn't know I was going to do movies I
just wanted to do stand up at that time
I had been doing stand up about 3 years
I had started in Denver had gone to New
York I'd want gone back to Colorado I'm
at war with my [__] wife and I had
like odd jobs I work for a sports
betting service but this whole time I
wanted to do standup so I knew the pain
was so much that I just couldn't sit in
that [__] apartment and snort below
so I forced myself to go out and do
comedy every [__] nightly I forced
myself like I didn't give a [__] if I
didn't have money there was this couple
that lived around the corner from me I
used she was Chinese I used to call her
white pow mom and his name was Sammy I
could always borrow a 20 from him to get
gas I worked with him to get gas or just
to get to a bar to do standup comedy
there was a bar named Murphy's in
Boulder it's still there I think I used
to go in there and just crack jokes at
the bar like I did so many [__]
things to get better eony like when I
think about it sometime I used to go to
a poetry reading where everybody stunk
like [__] armpit and Pugi juice it
was called I don't even [__] remember
what it was called Penny Lane and
Boulder it was a little [__] place
that was just a great coffee shop very
bohemic everybody in there had dirty
feet and stunk bad but they were nice
people and they used to have poetry
readings and and all that [__] and I
would go up there and do horrible jokes
during the Poetry readings and they
chased me chased me out they chase you
out the thing that saved me though the
chick that ran the place was a beautiful
girl and I knew her boyfriend from the
halfway house so when he couldn't come
out he was still in the halfway house I
used to write jokes at her coffee shop
all night and stay with her she became
one of my tightest friends and she
called different place she was like my
first manager not really manager that's
cool so she was a hippie chick that her
like her uncle was in the entertainment
business out here and I told her I want
to do standup and she would say just
come down to the coffee shop and get in
between the The Poetry readings I got
your back and then on I think on
Saturdays and Fridays she had to work
the 24-hour shift she was the manager so
they made her work from 11: to 6:00 in
the morning Jesus and I'd go in there
and sit with her there was a baker on
Monday his name was Joe cotch who I
still speak to today is one of my
closest friends really he used to bake
at lisio and he would take Tuesday and
Wednesday off so on Mondays he would
have to work a double shift so he would
come in at 4: to 12 and work his shift
on Monday night and then he would stay
from 12: to 8 and bake all the Tarts and
the ice cream and the gelates for the
next two days Jesus and I would sit with
him at the counter Le and he would give
me all the samples and I would write
jokes all night long I'd sit there and
and I had no idea what I was doing
please do not say Joey had it going on
no I would sit there all night eat smoke
dope outside and I'd maybe write four
jokes and I would write topical jokes
then because I was a host at the bould
the broker so on Monday nights I would
write the jokes for Tuesday kabish right
that's how I did it then that's crazy
that's [__] crazy now how did you
keep doing like how did you convince
yourself to keep doing it if you were
having all these issues like if you if
you bombed did you bomb every time you
went
up pretty [__]
much pretty [__]
much I was bombing in those days I was
bombing four nights a week four out of
six four out of seven four out of six
se and what like what was it in you that
was like okay I'll I'll go again like if
it's every time because I would switch
up I would do material and improvise and
some nights I just improvise and some
nights I just do material and I really
wasn't getting it I really wasn't
getting the the whole joke writing thing
it's funny I was at the comedy store
last night and I'm standing by the
freezer at the bar I ain't bothering
nobody you know I don't like walking in
the hallway I'm just standing there by
the freezer drinking award and Paulie
Shaw comes in and he orders a drink or
water and he says something to me like
nothing he nothing sarcastic I forget
what he said to me oh he said can you
believe this place is this packed he
goes I haven't seen this place this
packed since the [__] 80s tonight and
I looked right at him and I go I can't
believe I'm 50 and I'm still doing spots
at the [__] Comedy Store he goes I
know he goes me too I go I still
remember but being 1991 and
1992 and watching MTV comedy shows and
those days were a ton of comedy shows on
TV when I got into comedy in the early
90s there was comedy all over stand uh
television regular TV jez so you had
from 5 to8 you had comedy on MTV
kamakazi comedy good at all or not
really [__] yeah Felicia Michaels Paulie
Shaw Steve McGrew Todd Jordan like all
these guys like if you want like I know
that like Larry the Cable Guy was on it
under a different name Doug Stan Hope
was on evening at The Improv they used
to have evening at The Improv kamakazi
A&E presents Jesus Sunday mornings A&E
used to do standup comedy on Sunday
mornings it was hosted by Rosie O'Donald
and Bobby Collins oh [__] yeah there was
a ton of standup when I got into standup
but one of the stand-ups I was watching
at the time not for inspiration but he
was on everything was poly [__] sha
so he walks out and guess who the [__]
walks in Joe Tori walks in Joe Tori was
in the movie uh I forget with Tupac and
and Janet Jackson and he was in all
those house party movies
and Joe Tor on IMDb he's from uh he's
from St Louis and he uh he's got a
brother gy Tor that was an American
History X well let me tell you something
about Joe Tor and I've told this to Joe
Tori a thousand [__]
times I used to rent the rod danger
field special and the other tape I used
to rent yeah was the best of Death
Jam with guy with when he used to be the
warmup when Martin got promoted a a
black guy yeah yeah St Louis here it is
yeah St Louis Missouri what movies has
he been in been in a lot of stuff
um he was in NCIS he's NYPD Blue for an
episode I'm looking for some movies
House Party 3 all those kiden played
things yeah the three mus Hells I don't
know what that is yeah what the [__]
else was he in he was in that mov with
Janet Jackson Tails from the hood what
was it tals from the hood the hood
sprung locked
down he's been in a bunch of stuff he
was in a movie with uh with uh the
[__] the one dude Alex Baldwin's
brother and Lawrence Fishburn when they
escaped from jail he was at the strip
club with uh what's his name anyway Joe
Tor was fled Joe Tory was one of the
guys he had a joke about his brother was
one of them save the whale [__] and
[__] and he goes you know he don't
believe in guns but I believe in guns he
goes I love carrying my gun in
fact I go to the ATM at night dressed up
in a tuxedo with a gun I take money out
of the thing waiting for somebody to
come out of the bushes that was one of
my favorite jokes at that time really
and I watched that special over and over
and I used to see him when I first got
to the store and I would tell him this I
would tell him the bit and he'd die like
who the [__] remembers that stupid [__]
and I go I do because I studied it I
studied the timing I studied the words
you know I studied everything you know
so here was two guys last night at the
store yeah that I came up watching not
emulating but learning from you know how
does it make you feel that there's a lot
of young Comics looking at you like that
right now I think they're [__]
crazy I think they're [__] crazy
really it's embarrassing why cuz it's
[__]
embarrassing it's [__] embarrassing
when I go out and young Comics come up
to me go hey man you're the reason I do
comedy my [__] I don't want to hear that
I feel like breaking inside like you're
[__] up you're [__] up if I if I
made you do stand up or anything you
[__] up but how do you think like Joe
Tori felt like he must have felt sort of
similar it must be kind of normal to
feel that way if you if you really love
that sort of stuff it's probably not a
good
sign well listen man I remember the
first time I went to Lenny Clark and I
go when I watched you on that thing I
put a suit on after that he influenced
me to put a suit on for a long time I
just couldn't sell stand up with a suit
on I just couldn't [__] sell it it
was to people nah it don't work it don't
[__] work for me it's like a barrier
in my [__] head now I've always
wondered that so like you have to try
that out how how many times do you try
out wearing a suit before you're like no
three months every night not every I I
had like four different suits okay so
for a little while in Boulder I wore a
suit and then in New York City I wore a
[__] really badass [__] suit color
matching shoes and I just didn't sell it
I just didn't sell it once I started
dressing normal I sold it do you put any
thought into what you're wearing or is
it all is it just whatever you want to
wear or dog I'm the electrician I'm the
[__] electrician I look like a
[__] electrician I still wear Adidas
1980 sneakers what does that tell you
yeah I could care less what's in style I
don't even know what's in style I know I
don't like tight jeans around my legs
and I don't I don't want my jeans
falling down I've lived a life with my
pants [__] falling down I should get
a nickel every time I see a kid with his
[__] pants falling down so that's how
I [__] feel about that I when I dress
I like to be loose I don't like tight
clothing right if I'm worrying about my
clothes I'm doing something wrong wrong
if I'm going to do stand up and I'm
worrying about my outfit I'm doing
something wrong I should be worrying
about my set right that's all I want to
worry about that's all I don't care what
I have on my feet I want to look
presentable I mean I don't want to go up
there with holes in my [__] clothes
and stinking like 10 dead [__] back
dead [__] you know but I want
to look presentable I want to look like
I feel inside I want to look like I walk
around I don't want to look like nothing
why would I go up there with a tuxedo on
a [__] Martini if I don't [__]
walk around with a martini right you and
me talking as men right now for people
who are home when I see a comic with a
[__] cocktail in his hand on stage I
want to go up there and break it over
his [__] head because I know when
they're up there cuz they're alcoholics
and I know when they're up there they'll
be [__] cool there's a big difference
and it's a detraction yeah there's
nothing I want to do more than smoke a
[__] cigarette and I join up on stage
back to back with a bottle of Coca-Cola
with GL ice cubes but would take away
from the audience me trying to be
[__] Joe cool how do I know because I
tried it already I could I can't wait to
smoke a joint on stage that's my [__]
dream Le to take a joint three [__]
joints and that's how I know it's time
to get off when the joints are the three
joints are done it's abandoned ship
that's it what do you want to talk about
you already smoked three joints and you
did your [__] time what do you want
to talk about you roll three nice
[__] numbers three different weeds a
couple things of water Maybe maybe a
[__] half a sandwich like a little
turkey sandwich sometimes you want to
talk and [__] eat and tell a little
you know what add to the flavor you spit
lettuce and onions out of your mouth
sure you understand what I'm trying to
say to you and I don't want to go up
there and act or have something on that
I wouldn't [__] wear I don't wear a
[__] leather jacket when I walk
around and I wouldn't want to emulate
dice in that department I wear sneakers
I wear jeans they always got one hole in
them somewhere by the ass the pocket I
always got a hole somewhere a nice
[__] t-shirt that smells okay I don't
know what this I don't know you look at
my body you think you think a [__]
head shot or something could save this
face this is what it is so the first
four years though like when you were in
Denver or wherever I experimented I'm
not going to lie to you I experiment you
care more about all that stuff it's not
that I cared more listen I always knew I
wasn't [__] Elvis and I'm not one of
those guys that's going to become Elvis
I come at you with what I come at you
I'm not a [__] I'm no uh uh Rock
Hudson you know what I'm saying but I'm
no [__] son of Sher in the movie The
Mask
either you know I a walking around with
a big head with a scarf you know
[__] I don't [__] know Lee what
are you getting me started for that's
your new that's your new outfit on stage
so yeah do you did you ever think cuz
they they they don't do it that much
anymore but for a while all the Comedy
Central specialist had like weird sets
behind them did you ever think about
like what yours would be brick that's
all you want brick
you don't want like a little basketball
hoop brick I forget who had one it was a
terrible one he was like a basketball
hoop a scoreboard I forget who it was I
don't want nothing listen I need all the
help in the world I need with
standup I want them to focus on the
Stander you know Eddie Murphy had an
outfit on that was off color the first
two shows to make you focus on him I
tell you who's a genius with that is
Ralph May Ralphie May always wears
something on a special so if you're
switching the channels and you see a fat
guy with an orange jacket on you're
going to [__] stop that's brilliant
that's Ralphie May type [__] is that
just to catch people's eyes that's
different [__] things that you do
it's it's not marketing it's called
something else it's in a different area
I think it's just uh it sounds like it's
just you guys figure it out like you
okay if I'm going to go up at 1:00 a.m.
on a Saturday I need people to look at
me how am I going to do that we were
talking to somebody was in here talking
about acting and we're talking about
people who put the outfits on like when
they're auditioning a baker yeah if you
dress up like a baker when you get to
your car pull the gun out and put it in
your mouth don't even leave a note
they're going to know when they find you
in the baker suit that you're a [__]
moo anyway you don't give in that much I
want you to give me the illusion sell me
the illusion you're a baker without that
[__] apron on well cuz at that point
everyone's going in with it has a baker
me I'm going to go with a white t-shirt
that says like [__] your mother in the
ass on it because the white T-shirt is
still going to make me a
baker but without the the [__] collar
and the bop and the hat on and the apron
do you follow what I'm saying so I'm
still giving you the pis but I'm not
giving you the pis I'm putting one
finger in your [__] not four that's
nice of you you know what I'm saying I
don't want to [__] [__] up I just want
to do what's right and go home call it a
[__] day right but that's what when I
do stand up at night I don't [__]
know listen I do laundry my wife does
laundry whatever's in that [__]
hamper that's it I ain't going to lie to
you yeah if I'm doing something for Ari
I got to look nice I will do it you know
when I fly now if I get upgraded I do
dress up Sebastian when he came on the
podcast he made me think about that in
the 70s when you flew you were
impeccable
you were impeccable suit and stuff you
wore a suit the kids wore a suit the
women the little kids had ponytails the
girls you wor you were impeccable when
you got on the plane so what you we
absolutely now I wear jeans that look
nice and now I wear a nice college shirt
really yeah I'm In First Class if they
upgrade you you can't be a Puerto Rican
all your [__] life you can't be a
[__] felon all your life man so you
know they're doing me a favor by giving
me an upgrade one of I got to go there
with a t-shirt with holes with my hair
all [__] up and be all [__] no I'm
I'm going to give them the best I can be
so now and I just figured this out like
47 guys don't don't look at me like Joey
no you should be doing this [__] if
you're not doing it because your friends
ain't doing it and set a [__] example
that's what I think yeah you know you
got to have to look halfway decent I see
guys going on planes with flip flops
what if this [__] plane goes down and
you lose your flip plop and you're
walking around like Paulie in the weeds
down in Jersey with one shoe [__]
missing that time the [__] you going to
do the [__] but you when you travel
you want to you want to wear flip flops
you go to the beach you go behind your
house you don't wear flip flops on the
outside things could go down and he you
got a flipflop on you got to kick
somebody in the head with your [__]
toe now you broke your [__] foot now
they're looking for a limp now they're
looking for a dude with a [__] you know
what I'm saying you always wear your
[__] shoes you want to wear flip
flops when you're with your bra jumping
up and down at home that's fine but you
can't wear flipflops on a [__] plane
with your feet out like that like a
[__] animal
Sebastian's correct he's correct he
reminded me of that was he he wasn't it
was AO that was the one when you were on
the Southwest flight together with that
freaking guy just uh you there's
sometimes that you have to uh I'm not
[__] Johnny GQ I used to love wearing
a suit as a kid me too I got four or
five suits in that closet I got a nice
jacket I wore for the premier Grudge
Match I wore for Grudge Match that's it
the [__] I got a leather jacket
that's brilliant I've wore four times
you know when do you get a chance to
wear a Le a Le jacket in La this is like
bulletproof this [__] thing but they
almost make you feel bad about it out
here dressing up like i' I've had when I
was going on job interviews I never once
the only job interview I ever dressed up
for out here was uh the UFC in Vegas and
I wish I hadn't well I I might have got
if I hadn't but it was uh it's kind of
weird how they they kind of everywhere
else you're supposed to wear a suit and
get nice and here listen if I pay for
the UFC tickets if I paid $11,000 for a
[__] UFC ticket right I'd walk in
that [__] with a jock strap on
and a pirates hat and work boots on
$1,000 I pay I dress what I want as long
as it's legal right nobody could say
nothing for you if you walk into a UFC
event with a [__] jock on as long as
you don't show your dick you know it's
freedom of speech you got your work
boots on that's sanitary and you got
your little Pirates hat on with a little
[__] skull on your chest I think we
found you new Halloween costume but when
Joe Rogan gives you a nice ticket right
yeah well you going to go in there dress
with a picture Hitler on your shirt
trying to be [__] you know Johnny uh
Rebel do that on your own [__] time
you're in here on Rogan's dime or one of
your uncles's dimes or somebody else's
dime you're all right but your other
friends but Joey why am I you know when
I did the longest show at the premiere
guess what I wore to the premiere what I
wore a warm up go ahead call me an
[__] to my face cuz I have it coming
you know why I wore that because Adam
Sandler used to wear whatever he [__]
wanted when I went to the premier I
looked at Michael Irvin and I looked at
Roman OS I looked at the wrestlers they
were all dressed to the nines you know
how bad I felt because I thought it was
cool to be cool no it's not your mom
taught you to [__] dress up [__]
dress up for those events that happened
once in a lifetime that's why when I got
the chance to go to Grudge Match I
dressed to the [__] nines I went to
the bank and everything I don't go to
the bank for [__] one of those poista
suits from Hollywood three suits for
$200 people can't smoke around you
really that bad cuz I was going to get
them when I lose all the weight that
[__] Lee that those suits are Lee listen
I mean unless you're hanging out with
[__] versace's ghost and businessmen
who wear $1,500 suits which I love to
wear I just don't have a purpose for
those for me to go and buy a, 1500 suit
to impress you or my wife or the
neighbor to hang in the closet there's
no investment there's nothing it's just
a $1,500 suit working you know hanging
in your
closet fat guys like me chubby cute guys
like yourself you go to Hollywood you
get those three suits for a deuce all
right they give you a shirt and they
give you socks and they give you a belt
the shirts you're going to wear one time
you're going to throw those away cuz you
rip the [__] thing uh and the socks
it's made by some Korean blind guy one
sock is size 12 the other size eight you
know you don't know what the [__]
going on with your feet next thing you
know half a foot's up your heel is out
it's itching during the meeting forget
the socks you go buy your own nice socks
and your own nice shirt to match but
those suits for 200 bucks is three suits
what's that come out to $65 a [__]
suit yeah that's crazy okay let's say
you wear the suit three or four times a
piece what you not what you [__] not
really it's all going to no and let's
say you do and you go out to dinner with
your wife and you get caught on a
hook okay your mother-in-law is going to
be able to fix it but it's a $200 it's a
$65 suit even if you ruin the pants you
still kept it jacket and you didn't make
that much of an investment in a [__]
suit when when when when I was really
broke and Josh Wolf gave me that check
for 500 bucks and I bought those three
suits and I gained 80 [__] pounds in
two months and I went to put the suits
on they didn't fit no more could you
imagine if I would have paid $ 500 for
that one suit Jesus and if you go there
and they look at the $500 suits it's the
same suits that under the three for2 200
oh really they just charge you more just
so you feel better about yourself but if
you go to the right there on Hollywood I
think like two or three of those places
and last time I went there I saw all the
dudes from my witness news there those
suits hold up if you [__] take them
to the dry clean and don't throw them
and wrinkle them and take the jacket off
and don't act like an animal for what
the [__] we do with a suit on it's not
bad now if you're an agent at CIAA and
you're parading those suits and you have
a meeting with Brad Pit I spit in your
face if I'm Brad Pit you show up with
that [__] Japanese [__] worm silk
or whatever the [__] it is I don't even
know nothing about material what the
[__] do I know who knows I I finished
The Sopranos last night and it was I
knew that the the Fade to Black was
coming but I was the reason I I I was
thinking about it I went and looked and
the season finale or series finale was
in O Dune of 07 and I was thinking about
how I had probably just graduated high
school or was just about to graduate
high school so when did you graduate
high school
07 2007 oh my God and I was think like I
was think I was when was your first year
of college 2008 I presume no 2007 well
yeah yeah 2000 and when did you graduate
college 20 I finished early 2010 wow and
I was thinking about I was like you
finished high school in 2007 yeah yeah
wow wow I never [__] thought about
that I have to take a break now now I'm
really getting [__] anxiety over here
like really 2007 I never looked at it
from that perspective yeah no it was I
remember that so I graduated high school
25 years is before you and I got left
back one year so really 24 years if I
wouldn't have been a [__] 26 26
whatever but do you ever like look back
and like I remember the night I I
graduated I don't know I think it was a
little bit after this but I I remember
getting the call that I was going to
Israel for the first semester that night
and I drove to the graduation of my
shitty car and I was like I wonder if I
talk to me when I was graduating high
school how I would look at what I'm
doing right now
like if I think if I would have thought
I should have stayed with a job or what
whatever it was I was like I bet for
like 2007 Lee thinks this is pretty cool
like it's it's pretty fun and it just I
hadn't I I hadn't really stopped to
think about
it I was thinking about today this
weekend is your anniversary mhm and
you've been with this girl for 2 years
yeah wow that's crazy it's been a crazy
two years wow and you're in love you've
been in love with her since you met her
the first time she brought you home to
eat those tamales you were [__] done
you [__] Jews love Spanish women and
black women oh they're great what the
[__] is wrong with you you guys got like
a weakness cell you know you don't [__]
they're completely different from our
mothers I think that's what it is
hilarious you're not the first person
that I you know you're not I look at
this type of stuff and I wow I was
thinking about that salsa record I put
out okay that's salsa record I put out
and I've had the story when we first
started the podcast I had
um Mike Kesler call okay and he spoke
about how his brother Steven the
pharmacist when he was in college he
went to NYU and he was Jewish on the
weekends in the in the early 60s instead
of going to Bar mitzah and [__] he would
go to Latin halls and he was a young kid
Mike and he goes I couldn't understand
it at night instead of listening to The
Beatles he'd listen to Spanish music and
dance around and he became the Mambo
Champion or the salsa Champion whatever
the [__] of 1963 and New York City a
Jewish kid and it wasn't that he was a
Mambo Dancer by Nature it was that he
liked Spanish women he said he ended up
Mar and Spanish when they still together
48 years and kids I don't I don't
remember if you called when I I don't
remember I could cuz I've heard and hash
and Sopranos is with black women so I've
heard the stereotype but it's remember
when he goes uh she liked you and he
goes I don't know if you've looked at
this she's a bit light for my taste yeah
well Jonathan
wolf yeah like he married a black chick
David wolf married a black chick it's
it's really
uh it's not that it's uncommon you know
I I just you were dating a couple women
before Paula yeah but I remember you
going out with Paul a few times and
saying like this is the one I don't
remember when it cuz we talked for like
3 weeks to a month before cuz we met
online and then what I think it really
was is she got sick toward the beginning
of us dating and I had met her parent
her mom yet but I went down there when
she was sick and I and we watched we
watched The Exorcist on her bed during
the middle of the day on a laptop but
and then her mom cooked and I think I
think that was probably it like that was
very nice to you you did a very nice
move well it's just it's uh I see how
it's like the 4th of
July it's basically turning into my
family out here I don't really have
family family I'm sure if I get married
my mom might move out we who knows but
it just it was was uh it was great and I
actually I haven't even told Paul of
this I'm not sure if I'm going to be
able to do it but I I'm I signed
up for uh Spanish class at Valley
College it's Monday and Wednesday
mornings now let me ask you this very
interesting question I want you to be
strictly honest with myself from people
who listen when you got in that [__]
car and pointed that car West yeah did
you have any idea that you were going to
fall in love with a woman like Paul at
all before you even [__] answer
because you're I'm putting you in [__] a
tremendous bad
situation
uh I mean before you could even [__]
answer when you were sitting there on
the 4th of July eating with these people
kissing Paula they're treating you like
a
son did you ever think back of getting
in that car and seeing yourself they're
like who would have thought I had like a
year this is what I love about why I
tell these dumb [__] stories because
this isn't about drugs this is about how
I left New Jersey and you got embraced
you found yourself at somebody's home
you were at my home eating like I
remember you coming over me going this
[__] guy's great like look at him he
wants to go to New York I remember
calling you scared like going like you
were scared that night oh my God I
thought you were going to hang up on me
like I'm not going to New York this old
guy wants to [__] me in the ass no you
were like I'm in let's get the donations
and I'm like this [__] and I'm thinking
to myself when this guy got in this car
was he thinking of this moving this fast
like and I'm sorry I didn't let you
answer the question I just got so
emotional thinking I remember when it
was happening to me I remember being
working on the 4th of July building a
wall with bricks and
hitchhiking back to my home and snow
mass and barking and all of a sudden
John Denver pulling over and picking me
up and driving me up the corner to my
house up in uh up in uh wherever the
[__] I lived in snow Mass Village and
walking and going when I got in that car
for months ago I just wanted to survive
yeah I thought I was coming out here to
be an an editor I thought I was coming
out here to to like work a job and and
then that I'm very thankful for my first
job but it was also very tough on me
because I like when things move fast I
get very bored when things are are slow
or it it like that that summer my first
summer here was dead because the show
was on Hiatus and they were very nice to
keep me there but there was nothing to
do so when you called me that night it
was like midnight I was working nights
and you're like do you want to go to New
York I was like [__] yeah I want to go
and shoot the documentary so for
people you answered your own question so
for people who are at home thinking
about making a move not to LA to
anywhere anywhere that makes you that in
your heart we always have this fear and
all a sudden a year later you find
yourself on a dinner table with these
people that are complete strangers and
they're treating you like you've known
them for 20 [__] years yeah and if
you're not not real if you don't think
back to where you came from for 30
seconds and go wow a year
ago to move the
car
sure she what
oh if you don't think to yourself for
one minute how that uh I'm over here
talking to myself that's the weirdest
[__] thing people knock on the the
door for a bathroom key tremendous
that's when you know shit's going down
the [__] tubes you know what I'm
saying but we were on to something I
forget you know people who want to leave
and proc
procrastinate cuz trust me when I first
made the Hurdle from New Jersey the
[__] Aspen or the snow Mass Village
of Bol Jesus Christ I had a thousand
doubts and I could have been one of
those people that said well I'll do it
in a year I'll save up money that's like
the same thing of I'm not going to join
Jiu-Jitsu Tom in shape right okay I'm
not going to join karate till I'm in
shape I'm not going to go here till I'm
in shape it's the same fundamental well
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to get a job at a liquor store and I'm
going to put money away you're not going
to put dick away you're not going to put
dick away you're going to get a girl
pregnant you're going to get yourself
into a bad predicament right when I
thought about going to Colorado it was
like a 3-we process for me it was like a
3-we process I had a bunch of irons in
the fire I just had to rob somebody to
get a little financing and I was gone
hoop and listen I didn't have family but
I had family
okay I had family and I could have
turned my life around 10 [__]
thousand times and I [__] didn't and
I escaped but the one thing you know
last night I'm standing there guys I've
been living out here for 18 [__]
years I've been around a lot of [__]
people there was a minute last night
where I'm standing there going this is
surreal this is a dream that 20 years
ago I was in a basement apartment
watching paully shore on MTV I used to
watch the real world then yeah with the
Cuban kid that had the AIDS and the
chick fell in love with them this is
like the third I don't even know what
year please don't quote me on what year
this like '92 93 94 95 there was a kid
on MTV a Cuban kid that had AIDS and it
was the real world there was a cute girl
on there and there was some guy that
used to come to the store spaz or Raz or
Kaz he used to go to The Comedy Store
and they threw him off because he said
the guy had HIV on TV I I don't [__]
know but I used to watch Paulie and then
at night I'd put that tape in and watch
Joe Tori and I'd watch Bill Hicks on the
[__] Rodney thing and there'd be
nights I ain't going to lie I'd [__]
cry because I wanted to do this so
[__] bad I could taste it like I I
thought if I could just go on stage and
somebody could see me that maybe I had a
[__] chance nobody ever saw me you
know what I'm saying well yeah what
[__] Lisa at I was laughing before
cuz we were talking before the podcast
started about Jujitsu and we were
talking about a movie and you just said
come here and I just started laughing
cuz we were we're literally on the floor
of an office building in the back of
North Hollywood and I'm getting on top
of Joey
Diaz in the half guard or you're in half
guard and I'm getting on top of you and
I'm like who would have thought like
when I was listening to one of those
first rogans on my drive out here I'm
like I'm getting on top of like that it
was just I had to laugh for a second I
just had no I was like what is happening
in my life now this is [__] life and
this is why if you're scared of making a
move Jesus Christ 300 bucks you got a
dive in a hotel down in Hollywood you
get a job telemarketing look at [__]
diegoo selling that [__] inking [__]
on the phone yeah he's making bang I
told him just sit still for 90 days wait
till everybody quits and you get all
their leaves they promoted him he now
gets people who called in oh cool so he
don't have to call [__] uh dentist
and [__] people in Afghanistan to
sell them a box of tape oh cool
and here has a new podcast
too oh
[__] uh oh uh oh oh [__] go what's up
buddy what's happening my brother I'm
happy you called in we wanted to switch
it up a little bit tonight and we said
[__] it let's have Danny be call in and
[__] things up and what's the latest
with
Gary my brother oh god well I know that
he just got 25 years for One bank
robbery and he's waiting on the other
two uh there was it was more than we
thought in the beginning you know
originally we thought he took down One
bank but turns out he took down a couple
of banks some lady that owned the
restaurant followed her home put a
pistol to her head grabbed and it's
somebody we knew growing up in North
North Bergen one of our friends mothers
of all things followed her home to I
think Richfield fs and got her at the
doorsteps so he he's pretty much done
three strikes you're out well actually
it's like six strikes for him was
fouling off a couple of pitches but they
you know I don't know bro I I don't I
don't see him coming out I think that's
it no no has he reached out to anybody
or oh no he he did you know he did no he
went out ugly man he went out hating
everybody and he was drug induced so you
know everybody was supportive everybody
helped him out and he kind of went out
ugly he went out you know like a
gangster and now he's kind of doing time
on his own it's it's a shame but he
burnt all of his Bridges including us
here you know my mom passed away so he
lost that
Lifeline uh Michael my cousin everybody
people out west by you uh yeah so he's
kind of sitting there I'm not saying
I'll never speak to him again but uh
right now he's kind of kind of dealing
with what he created if you will Danny
you and I both know that there before
the grace of God go ey that could have
been Us by
mistake well you know what he had a he
had a lot of help a lot of people were
there for him you know it wasn't his
first mistake it wasn't his second
mistake and you know you know drugs man
that's it drugs he couldn't just be
happy smoking a joint or having a drink
or he had to go on the powder you know
and then he became typical Gary North
Bergen style you know like was
1985 uh no control you know he thought
he was smarter than everybody he was
going to outthink the cops and all the
cameras were like d you can't Rob this
ain't
1995 this is everybody's got cameras
everywhere you go there's cameras but he
you know he knew more than everybody and
like I said he he's going to be swimming
a long time can you imagine Danny
getting caught selling powder now and
you get caught on camera from across the
street they got cameras the size of a
[__] dime they put in bars I heard
now and yeah you know what thank God I I
left that that lifestyle many many years
ago as you did I couldn't make a living
now there's no way you can make a living
as a thief there's no Way's no no no no
no hey Lee what's up Lee how are you
about what up Danny even under the radar
yesterday I was watching something and
they had closed off Studio City did you
see that yesterday for 4 hours no where
they closed off Studio City because
three guys they got spotted breaking
into a house and the one guy had a
weapon so they evacuated the maids and
I'm sitting there going in all my years
that's what saved me I always craw
through that window solo I could have
been a [__] burglar or an
encyclopedia salesman cuz I dressed
apart that's how I did it I didn't walk
in a neighborhood with a hooded
sweatshirt with a [__] born to lose
t-shirt on I'd walk looking halfway
decent you didn't know what the [__] I
was
doing you didn't know what the [__] I
was doing I could have been doing
anything well you know Gary did a lot of
his stuff all messed up too he wasn't
thinking levelheaded he was up for two
or three days and he dragged some young
kid with him uh actually the the the
getaway driver died not you know of uh
she was sick to it was a girl she died
of complications and the young kid
flipped on Gary and uh told him about
the uh the other Heist you know again
they had him for the bank in Fu up there
by White Castles and uh then they got
him for I think two more banks in in the
poor lady that owned a restaurant on
Tunnel Avenue I forgot her name but it's
somebody that we knew was her mother you
know and uh yeah it's a shame you know
he's sitting there by himself we've you
know since my mom died everybody's kind
of doing their Coco you know she kind of
kept us a little bit talking and she
passed away last September and we've
kind of all lost contact you know
everybody's mat she was The Matriarch
Danny she was the [__] glue she was
the
glue yeah she was when the mother and
the when the mother and the soprano died
The Sopranos was over people will tell
you real people who know what was going
to go down we'll tell you that day
Olivia died that was it for The Sopranos
they that's why David Chase is a genius
because he bailed something out that was
supposed to go one way and it went a
different way and he kept your attention
that's the genius of David Chase but a
lot of people who knew that's so true a
lot of people who knew what was going to
happen knew that fox knew the mother was
going to end up the boss of the family
oh I see so when she died it was all
over they had to go a different
direction so they play a little hard
ball and then they won a direction and
that's how they ended the [__] show
that's the genius of David Chase well
kind of when she died the the storyline
was all messed up I didn't I only
enjoyed it the first couple of years two
or three years whenever she died after
that it wasn't the same you know it was
like they were reaching but she reminded
me kind of of my mom you know take the
take the knife out of the ham and stick
it right here she had that you know
tough my mother was tough but yet she
was scared at the same time you know she
you know but she you know she made good
chicken though you remember that chicken
she can cook some fried chicken Coco she
was good at that I must have ate Danny
[__] 40 and in those days I used to
snort and eat whenever there was food
like I'd eat those sandwiches at Joan
Joan Mary used to put this bar we grew
up and it was on the corner or whatever
in Burger Line Avenue they were nice
enough to put these ham and cheese
sandwiches in this circle thing like a
bakery Circle and you pick up the thing
and take the sandwich out and put it
back down but for some reason there was
always a fly in the one at Joe Mar's I
would eat 15 of those [__] sandwiches
and I get a bag of potato chips with hot
sauce on
it Franks hot sauce with potato chips
and a mug of Budweiser [__] [__] you
don't know I couldn't touch a [__] I
couldn't eat [__] if I snorted a line
that was it I'd look at [__] food and
puke like that kid from South Park when
he looks at that girl wow that's kind of
how I am with with the but you know what
that was was a long time ago you know
but yeah I always do remember the food
out there and they were putting it out
so we didn't you know we had a little
something on our stomach and then at
night late night at 12:15 Cowen would
close chicken uh chicka D the chicken
delay Chicken Delight no Chicken Delight
was down Chicken Delight was two blocks
down where Burl work chicken D was next
the door to us chicken you're right
Chicken Delight was on 78th
Street Chicken Delight don't cook
tonight called chicken like d that had
tremendous fries and next to it was the
wing Fong Chinese restaurant how many
times did I gone and dash out of that
[__] but up the corner God I'm
sorry what what was the chicken joint on
78 that was the one Mike donala worked
in right on 70 right across the street
from my house I remember when we didn't
go to school he had the keys we'd skip
school we'd go up there we'd fry up some
scallops some shrimp some chicken and go
in the
clubhouse uh and smoke Weedle they burn
candles to keep warm and you know uh
that that [__] that seemed like
yesterday Co that's like 40 years ago
for Christ sakes 1975 1976 77 you know
what I just came back from Kate May man
it was really nice I bumped in I told
you earlier Pete manuso we we knew him I
played baseball with him you know who we
he's good friends with Jimmy valano all
those guys so we're starving we're
looking for a place to eat we find a
pizzeria on the boardwalk and we pop in
there we started talking and where you
from Burg oh so am I well it turns out
he owns a a pizzeria Jimmy volano was
popping in the next day you know and uh
Kate May it's a it's a great place we
went down to do some uh shark fishing
there shark hunting I want to call it
did you get any but you went to the
wrong place down in North Carolina
they're biting they're biting people
every 15 minutes in North Carolina
you're up New
Jersey yeah but here's what you do
though there's people that owe your
money you tape them to boogie boards and
you cut their legs and then the Sharks
come that way and that's how we started
getting them now really really it's a
really nice place down there but I don't
go in the water I'm always [__]
around no sharks for me pal I put my
feet and then that's about it and now
they're coming up and pulling you on
there they pull you the [__] in those
sharks something happened know those
Shar [__] [__] they taking that Shar
NATO serious [__] you now when this
football season start my friend you're
ready to rock well officially let's look
uh August 9th
preseason
no one's going to bet on pre do people
bet on preseason [__] yeah that's it
well you can't you don't know who's
going to play People BET on everything
Jesus and if they don't bet you got to
talk them into bet that's what he
does hey Lee here you go here's a here's
some advice take a like a rookie coach
who's hungry for wins out the door
certain teams of course they don't want
to risk their Stars they already know
what they got but teams that are looking
searching for that backup quarterback
find a team that has a good backup
quarterback cuz he's going to be playing
hard too but if you have a rookie
quarterback a rookie coach rather he's
hungry he wants to start off you know
with a winner so preseason yeah stay
away from it if you don't know what
you're doing of course but there's money
to be made but It's Tricky and you only
bet a few dollars you don't get crazy on
it cuz like anything can happen but yeah
it's right around the corner baseball
Allstar break uh after this weekend
times flying kids are old your girls
about two and a half now three getting
up there two and a half I got to ask you
something I'm really happy that you
called because before Lee Lee graduated
ready for this Danny sit down for a
second you I am I'm sitting Lee
graduated high school in
2007 did you I just realized that I had
no idea I had no idea you're feeding him
pot and stuff like that man get in
trouble he ate 500 milligrams the other
night we both did I got to tell you
something I was [__] gone I went home
I ate [__] a captain booty I ate the
[__] peaches I ate every banana oh my
God oh my God peaches make me [__] I
can't do peach what do you think it did
to me the next day I was all [__] up y
I puked he puked from the 500 milligram
he ate wholesale torini I didn't every
time I PUK talinis they got talinis were
coton it now my God no no no no no he
went home and made uh talini old
talini was fire and he put that spray
butter and it mixed with the expiration
he got sick yeah then he blam then he
blames on the [__] brownie this
[__] guy it was a I [__] I had a
Tony surprise I was leaning up against
my fridge talking to somebody who wasn't
there I was in the I was having
cold listen I had a little I just [__]
around with those tootsie rolls and that
was enough to [__] scare me straight
man I will never do that none of that
edible stuff again oh my God so just
give me a joint give me my weed I like
cutting it up I like smelling my fingers
I like the whole presentation of it and
cheap I gave him cheap I gave him bck 75
you give the whole thing no I gave him
half this Danny beon cool I give him
what I [__] give him he's been around
so was like two and a half times of what
you had I almost yeah but next we're you
know we're we're here on the East Coast
we don't we're not privy to that stuff
you know we get some we get some smoke
and good weed here but you guys are
spoiled out there man you got the like
you said torini po now no he went home
he went
home dannny before before we were
talking about him graduating high school
and what he was thinking about that he
went to college and then one day he got
up and like you and I did he uh he uh
got on up and got in his car and came
out of here something that people from
our area don't even dream of doing right
you know when we were growing up it was
me and you and and we stayed away
everybody else go leaves for a year they
come back oh it's great [__] you guys
you loses and then 3 years later they
come back with some story the
grandmother died and they had to come
back and take care of the house but they
getting their [__] get they going back
we were the ones who stayed and you know
yeah like I think at times sometimes
towards the end I did all the creepy
[__] to get out of there and never come
back because it was so painful for me
growing up that that was in the back of
my mind psychologically I was like you
know what maybe I just did that [__]
towards the end just so I never had to
go back there but we were talking about
graduating high school and that's when I
really met you
8182 like I had no dream at all Danny
like when I was hanging out at Joan
Mary's and at Corky I had a dream of
being a drug
dealer and being successful that was it
or being a part-time Thief like like
James Khan and busting into jewelry
stores and making 30 grand and partying
for six months on an island then robing
again that was what I wanted my life to
be I didn't consider work I didn't
consider [__] movies I didn't
consider legit working at a way remember
we could all get a job at APA making
40,000 50,000 a year to start in those
days we could all get a job as a cop or
a fireman or a long Shan in those days
those jobs were there for us absolutely
they were right there it was just it was
I had no dreams Lee you were way ahead
of me I had no dreams my dream was to go
to corkies do an aball get those
Bluebirds for $2 a piece and hopefully
and hopefully get trites one them to
suck your dick B something you know what
I'm saying Lisa trites that's that's
right right that's old school They well
you know what I I we started hanging out
in early 80 81 82 uh but I didn't know
you in the 70s but yeah you were in a
different crew there but we all became
one crew you had the Robert fton and you
had the horis man and the Kennedy crew
and it seemed like in 8182 they all
clicked that Joe and Mary's the Midtown
corys Gregory whatever the name well my
world into you my real world into you
was a kid named Glen KY who I got to
tell you something our friend Fernie
popped up on Facebook and I had always
and I had always heard rumors and they
got confirmed he does look like he had
HIV my heart broke yeah because I had
heard rumors in ' 87 I called and
somebody threw him out of a Christmas
party because he was in the bathroom for
an hour and when they finally opened the
door he was shooting
and it broke my heart and you know I
feel guilty in a lot of ways about
Fernie I can't lie to you uh I can't
imagine why Glen KY won't talk to me I
mean I have he won't talk to nobody you
know it's funny I I said the same thing
I was up at uh Genie o Bram with his
brother Jason they have that they have a
Super Bowl party every year you know and
I keep asking where's Ki and they told
me he isolated himself John Mian would
they they were pretty good friends for a
long time and Mian told me that he'll
contact him once in a while but he he
came back to North Bergen after years of
not talking to nobody and had one all
nighter with the guys and that was it
and then he just basically turned his
back now this is what I heard I don't
know for sure because I always like
Glenn you know oh my God Glenn and I
yeah Glenn was a good kid I his brother
uh Keith too uh but Glenn's Glenn's
grandmother and my grandmother were
friends and so I knew Glenn before I
even came into North burgle when I still
than Fab you so I have a very long
history with him I was me and him were
glued to the hip from
79 to 84 he was I would take I would die
for that kid he knew it he [__] knew
it he knew that it whatever I had half
of it was always his you know and he was
a good athlete good
athlete he was uh he was my brother it's
I I still remember him and Fernie and
Hollow no him and Fernie driving me to
the airport when the cops were looking
for me when I was going to Sarasota to
hang out with Gary Hartman and I still
remember them both looking in the car
and they were both crying I mean we knew
I've always said it that moment was when
we knew the summer like that's it high
school was done whatever had happened
that summer it was over it was manhood
like the cops were looking for me they
wanted their jewelry back and here I am
on a plane to Sarasota who the [__] goes
to Sarasota to watch the r War Kim Don
lives down there to Sarasota but it's
just weird what what were you thinking
in 82 at that well you know what I just
got out of the army it's the summer of
82 I I I still feel that was my favorite
summer we were all young for me I had
some money I saved in the Army uh we
didn't have to work it was just a summer
of partying and going down to Seaside
crashing into one room with 15 people
best summer ever was the summer 82 and
then shortly after that September of 82
I headed out to California see I lived
out in California three or four
different three different times 81 to 83
88 87 to 88 93 to '94 so I lived in
California on several occasions and one
day I really hoped to get back there you
know if you get some [__] water
though I'm a coming out there till you
get water but uh yeah uh I've been
around the block you're right we we we
thought that was funny Le yeah we uh we
uh where we going to get water
from but listen uh most of the people
like you said cooko their version of
escaping is moving to Bergen County they
got away they really went far they went
two miles up the block well that area
it's not I'm not even making fun of them
that area you know it's like people
think oh when you beat the mob for 8,000
they're going to fly out the Tempe and
do what and do what what are they going
to do in Tempe rent the car you think
they got GPS and they're going to come
looking for you they don't know nothing
if you tell them you escape to Atlantic
City they'll shoot you [__] I it's
funny you said that in 83 uh James my
cousin you know James very well and GL
of course uh he old frank jumper from he
you know the gangster up in Richfield by
Mr Mr New Jersey whatever uh he owed him
about 10 Lodge and he owed this other
kid that I forgot his name so he owed
about 18 Grand and then he boogied he
came out to California and never left
never went back and then when I did get
back from California I bumped into Frank
Jumper in a Fruit Stand in [__] uh
West New York and I'm trying to avoid
him because he's a big [__] and I know
he's [__] dog this dude was Juiced up in
1983 on Deca Deca and more
Deca oh but he was a big andan you know
he was conected guy I didn't realize how
connected he was until he got pinched
and they tried to get me to testify
against him for lone shocking and Sh you
know who pinched him right William frech
pinched him you know who [__]
prosecuted him Governor chrisy actually
was a prosecutor that's [__] crazy
[__] I was just talking to somebody
about that that I ran into uh but yeah
so that's how James got out to
California owning the mobster's money uh
but you're right you go to Atlantic City
they'll find you speaking of Atlantic
City man I'm telling you what if they
get this sports betting in the Jersey
which any day now we're we're waiting on
a ruling we're supposed to be in already
but I tell you what it'll be big I don't
know if it'll cure Atlantic City's
problems because the place is really
hurting but it'll definitely open up
some uh Avenues and maybe start the
recovery you know for Atlantic City and
if it is legal I'm moving my ass out of
Pennsylvania to New Jersey he listen I
ain't giving out no inside information
but if I wanted to bomb some place
that's what I would bomb Atlantic City
you're doing every be a favorite just
bom 50 miles around and start from
scratch dog start from scratch down
there they just couldn't bring that's
why I went down to Kate May man because
every every summer twice or twice a
summer every year rather we go down to
Atlantic City and the same [__] we you
stay at the Revel or one of the nicer
places but this year we said [__] it
let's go down to Kate may try and it's
so like nice you know the people are
good they they're not crowded it's very
Victorian those Shores are crowded now
I've seen the pictures and it's [__]
amazing how many people could be on the
beach I refuse to be on a beach if
somebody was 4 feet from me I don't care
whether she was beautiful young I don't
give a [__] I don't want to be 4 feet
from somebody I grew up when you had 10
feet away from you you could fart and
scratch your [__] and [__] you can do a
thousand things on the beach now you
have people right on top of you on
Seaside and all those po of place and
you still fart you go see you don't go
there you got to go down to where where
people can't you got to go where people
can't aford where they can't afford it
and let me tell you we went from Kate
May the kids wanted to go to the
boardwalk which was only like 7even
eight miles to uh Wildwood I haven't
been to Wildwood for [__] years 30
years I haven't been to Wildwood
beautiful when I was a kid I don't know
what dude you kidding me now it's a huge
Boardwalk there's literally three
amusement parks on the boardwalk and
it's like four miles
long and it's night and day you go from
like you're at a different world six
miles up the beach you know you got the
people at the store smoking cigarettes
on you're saying come on in we got a two
for one special bring the kid in I'm
like okay but what a [__] want to
call white trash ball oh the epitome of
white trash is [__] the Wildwoods
these days uh but yeah we we go to where
people can't afford it you know not
trying to be stuck up or anything but
that's what you do you want to be left
alone you got to pay the extra money and
you're left alone let me tell you
something that's what I found out let me
tell you how tight I was with Glen kanty
and I want people to wrap their hands
around this freshman to sophomore summer
again freshman to sophomore summer it
was this time
around 35 years ago we were kids that me
Glen KY and John Bender went in on a
summer house in Seaside Park New Jersey
for two weeks your we talked to our
parents two weeks to go down it I hit
the number in February for 2500 my mom
took five off the top 500 I had 2,000 in
a bank account my mom goes don't touch
it I [__] took that money I started
buying quarter pound from Joo and I
started make my he became a cop too God
he became a cop he's on Facebook every
day he hates SPS and [__] nobody hates
[__] more racist than Joe and he's
still my brother I ain't mad at him I
love Jo D that [__] has my
baseball card collection let me tell you
something when I was in my yeah that
[__] that name brings a bell big time
well his two brothers were murderers the
one brother was a cop that got thrown
off on the other brother stuck the flag
pole up the gay guy's
ass the ceramic guy they stuff the
[__] Hammer up his [__] was a
ceramic gay guy when we were kids when
we were kids he used to make Ceramics so
the one brother went to jail that
brother robbed my house I had a 8 oz of
pot that somebody had cracked the seeds
in it so whenever you lit it it was like
explosive pot it was like those candles
that don't turn
off every time you
let every time you joint blew up oh
God Joey Ra's brother stole it and
that's how everybody knew that he had
robbed me because he was selling nickel
bags of
exp explosive weed exposive cocoa
pffs you know [__] Joey Ray so Gary
I'm in California I'm in California at
this point 87 I got this baseball car
collection it's this [__] interesting
story you know I got I come back from
California busted out and I know well
baseball cards in the late ' 80s were at
an all-time high so I figure I'm going
to sell these cards and I had every card
from 1970 to 1979 packed up so I'm going
to make a score I'm thinking it worth 30
40 50 Grand I come back and Gary tells
me oh man I'm [__] up turns out he got
caught doing something one night Joey
Rayo knows about my my baseball card
collection tells him I'll let you go if
you K me Danny's baseball card
collection so five years later I'm
hanging out with Scott Z
and the rum always was the thing on the
street was hey I got your yeah I know
everybody's got my baseball cards yeah
yeah yeah that's funny haha uh so no Zac
tells me no I really got him because he
wed up marrying or hooking up with Joey
rayo's ex his wife they got divorced so
sure enough there was my baseball cards
like seven years later five years later
but they took out all the Pete roses the
Tom cers all the you know the Johnny
benches and [__] and I still got those
cards to his day minus the the bigname
players but yeah man we had some [__]
up people in that town Jo was the first
his house is the first time I ever had
dark rye I almost lost my mind were like
ham and cheese on dark rye with mustard
it was the best thing I ever you
obsessed with dark rye for like I'm
telling you it was CU of Joe R I went to
his house once and his father made me a
ham and cheese sandwich on dark rye I
almost lost my mind I was a Cuban kid I
never had [__] dark r with the
[__] have you heard from anything about
satino
he's Mia he's living somewhere he's
missing somewhere another guy that was
my brother my brother yeah I grew up i l
him
funny know he got he got banged up man
he got banged up on that [__] he
couldn't same [__] like 1985 just the
same [__] left his wife his kids this
was two years ago three years ago they
were looking for him he was living with
mean on a couch he was still working for
UPS he got six kids he was coaching
baseball one day he went MIA listen man
you got to remember one thing again like
I always tell Lee I loved Anthony I grew
up with Anthony I grew up on Gard
Terrace he grew up on Charles Court was
right next to Charles Court AB I [__]
he lived next to the Iceman the guy who
was The Iceman's cousin the prong the
prong which John prongay on Facebook the
one brother he changed his name I found
him you know what I didn't want to
intrude his privacy I told Lee I was
going to contact him and put him on the
podcast and I said leave you know what
he went through enough that kid went
through enough why am I going to bother
and put him on the podcast and exploit
the [__] kid but satino was my
brother uh I went his mom used to give
me extra sandwiches she was the lunch
lady at McKinley good lady good lady
good
lady these people are who the [__] I am
they're Who I Am the Sabatinos that name
is in my head every [__] day it's the
funniest name I ever heard sa last time
I saw him was uh the summer of 2012 I
had my place up in we hawk and he called
me up he needed to borrow a couple of
dollars I hooked them up with I think
two or 300 bucks he looked like [__] I
asked him Hey listen you want to crash
here for a little bit he's like nah I
got to get home it's my kid's birthday
and that's the last I saw of him I think
it was June or July of
2012 because I ran into him and Mian you
know because I was up there for about I
don't know about two years you know I
had that place up and we Hawking and I
bought to me in and then I started going
out here and there with those two and
you know I started like what the [__] am
I doing I got two kids these guys are a
train W still and it was fun I had some
laughs but I'm like oh I can see how
easy no no no you can't do that anymore
no I could see how easy you can fall
back into that that that [__] town
it's cursed it's [__] cursed it
really is at that first bar I would [__]
in my pants I can't even be around it I
can't even be in a bar no more Danny you
start sh the coke right you
start I can't even step in a bar at this
age like I'm um it's over like my
instincts just stop like people tell me
come to the bar next door it's not
happening it's never happening I cannot
go to a bar I do not want to see a bar I
saw enough bars growing up I don't I saw
a bar for [__] eight lifetimes you
know plus you're playing in the clubs
all the time too surround no man I grew
up you know I grew up uh in New York
City when it was New York City and I had
the extreme Fortune I was very fortunate
that I knew people and from time to time
I'd steal some money and i' go into
those little bars in Manhattan I go in
there with a grandma Blow by
myself and I know the best little spots
I don't know where they are now who the
[__] knows that was 20 years ago they
changed own I you know what I was a
notorious Party by myself too lot of me
too I love that [__]
I do I do like weird [__] like the guys
are leaving the city at 2 in the morning
I refuse to leave I'd be just like just
leave me here they like what are you
talking about I just just go I'll see
you tomorrow I'll take a cab home I
[__] find a little hole in the wall
Party by myself hanging out with
homeless people all types of [__]
weird [__] now I drink at home when I
drink I drink right at home with my wife
we have a couple of drinks and and
that's it we keep it fun we keep it safe
no homeless people
anymore what's that no home no once in a
while I'll grab a homeless guy just to
you know shake up the past a little bit
but uh we're going you know we're almost
married 15 years now you know we're uh
getting ready to go up next week to
celebrate a couple of days together
we're going to do some uh uh zip lining
up there nak they got naked ziplining
we're gonna try it out naked naked
zipline oh you laugh I'm not laughing at
that I'm just looking at Joey's face I
just my wife pretty stack too so I'm
just going to have I'm going to we're
going to zipline but we're going to keep
our clothes on kind of it was like that
shark story that never happened but
sometimes I do want to put people on
boogie boards and just float them out
there and cut them just to see what
happens like get out of the [__]
water you morons your [__] wonder One
You're get that's their water stay out
of their water don't go in the [__]
shark water you know F people are stupid
sometimes there I love you [__] sucker
we got a boogie out of here yeah yeah
boogie board don't go on the boogie
board but yeah listen it's always a
pleasure
and I Know You Walk This Way in
September I'm going to stop by and see
you in Manhattan in September Powell
have a good time I love you Danny B
thank you for taking the time you you
bring me back for [__] 20 minutes
people listen to us talking they're like
what the [__] lingo is
that what the [__] language is that that
these guys are talking all of a sudden
we sound the same don't tell me this
lady's knocking again with diarrhea I
love you I got to go Danny B stay black
he's gone oh he's gone already yeah holy
fu [__] who knocked on the door who does
this type of action very nice older
Mexican lady forgot her key to the
bathroom I was stoned to the [__]
bills and the owner came by earlier but
she was just she told us that she parked
in our space I was like we're getting
kicked out again like the past two ones
Jesus can we talk about this for
speaking of getting kicked out what you
knew I was nervous on Monday and you
called me like every 15 minutes saying
the cops are coming don't answer the
door don't answer the phone cuz I know
you hello and he made me promise you
like like don't answer the phone unless
it's a phone call from either me or
Paula like you're really serious about
it every 15 minutes cops are coming we
ate that bar of death the corova bar
th000 milligrams today we mixed it up
with some stars of De listen we got some
great pictures in the mail from the
great artist gra now I don't know my
[__]
Ferguson uh he wrote a little letter
here listen to you guys all the time I
hear Joey stories and it say that we
walk similar
paths he wanted to send some love don't
ever
stop Brady Ferguson he drew some nice
[__] pictures of us they're beautiful
we're going to revamp the studio here
and we get the music podcast going I'm
we going to put these up he did a
beautiful job I weigh like 400 lb in
that picture Brady [__] I love you
though and look at Lee you all Lee needs
is a [__] hat you got a part-time job
at Ming Fang's Chinese restaurant Ming
things Ming fings that's a new chain I'm
[__] inventing right there and [__]
what you think you're dealing with
[__] anyway some shout outs to my
main cocaine toal's always there for me
Mr Gonzo Casey Jones Greg and ly Powers
I got the email about Cuba let's make it
happen Paul Lynch Philip
Reyes I don't know what the [__] this is
wait for dust the black dude that's a
cool [__] that's a good guy and
Matthew melins I love you [__] suuck I'm
gonna be in Atlanta this weekend oh yeah
Atlanta I can't [__] wait and I'm
gonna be in [__] Chicago in two weeks
that's all you need to know then we're
doing the ice house it's going to be a
light sum at Le light sum I got to take
it easy I got to dip on the [__] 280
and then we'll talk business you know
what I'm saying I feel you dog but no
it's uh I had no aspirations I was going
to ask you about that what so you like
you
said when I like when you were
graduating all you could think about was
getting like drugs here whatever like
whatever you just told Danny when I
wasn't I don't from the time I can
remember I I was always thinking I want
to go to college to do this or to do
that or during High School I was really
worried about the college applications
and all that like if you were going to
talk to 17-year-old you what would what
was like on your mind like nothing of
that at all you were just thinking about
the
present
well because of the situation I was a
little
winded put it lightly your your mother
died of course I was a little winded and
once that college thing came up and that
whole thing with high school and me
dropping out and coming
back I just didn't feel
like somebody had spoken to me about
maybe getting scholarships and stuff and
I always thought about the
trades you know being a plumber or
Carpenter and [__] I knew the carpentry
wouldn't work because I figured I'd saw
my finger off I faint or
something so I knew that wasn't but I
really like
masonry but I couldn't get a book for
masonry in Jersey I had to get a a
Laborer's book and hopefully get put on
with masonry guys and work a certain
amount of days and then I could become a
laborer for the Mason something weird
there was a loophole so that was when I
went to
Colorado I I got into the masonry that's
what the story I was telling before was
the Fourth of July I worked for chip
chillson masonry and I remember that was
my first Fourth of July away from Jersey
ever like ever like I ever and here I
was working till lunchtime for like 15
bucks an hour he paid me time and a half
or something and then I was going to a
barbecue at a guy from New Zealand's
house and his wife when I got there it
was like 15 people there and here's this
kid you know like in the back of my mind
like that I'm like if they only knew
that I robbed the [__] jewelry store
less than a year ago with these people
even and I wouldn't say nothing I try to
be I didn't know who I was trying to be
I would talk about movies i' talk about
food I didn't talk about any of my
personal life in Jersey then nothing
they would ask I'd ask a few questions
North Bergen they would say oh
Bergenfield no Hudson County but
uh no I I if I was 17 I once read a
thing that if you went read The Wall
Street Journal for four years you got
more out of it than you had the college
education and then always stuck with me
for a while like do you really need a CO
college
education the only reason I was going to
college for my mother's witches right
but once I started taking night courses
I had to tell you I liked it I really
enjoyed it I I missed that today I I
would love to get a second chance of
going to college I I still wouldn't I
still wouldn't go to college as a ra ra
guy what does that mean I still wouldn't
go to I wouldn't get I know that for my
child for you as a young man I would
tell you to the way to make it in
college today is to get involved you
have to get involved you have to uh be
part of a group you have to mingle you
know you have to see other things you
have to sign up for all those workshops
they give you that's the only way you
get the most out of college yeah you
know but on the other side of me I know
that Lis I I should also work 20 hours a
week I live very contradictory so for me
I know
that I'm going to go sit and listen to
some black guy play the piano with a
little hat on and [__] and I got to make
believe I'm entertained I already heard
and seen this [__] right well it doesn't
I mean or whatever the [__] it is but
aspirations doesn't have to mean College
like it could have been it could have
been in high school you wanted to be a
comedian so you're going to go listen I
didn't aspire to go to college but I
didn't also want to be that guy that
didn't go to [__] college or at least
didn't [__] try okay with all the
opportunities available to you how the
[__] can you not want to go to college
you know there's a [__] paperwork
there's [__] that you could do to get
into some college and get some type of
[__] degree no matter how dumb you
are there's a college somewhere that'll
take you am I lying to you am I lying to
you no as long as you pay the [__]
tuition there's Valley College you get a
degree in [__] Philosophy from Barry
can I can you not yeah it's the same
[__] degree you're going to get from
somewhere else and when you go into that
interview and you interview it doesn't
matter whether you got you've told me
yourself it doesn't matter what it says
in that even though the other day I did
see a girl with Emerson shirt on and I
almost said something to them I go what
the [__] it's the 4th of July what why
would you talk to me right and that
that's really all it is is that's the
the they want to see that you attended
that's it and then they might call a
reference yeah he attended here did he
really get bees yeah was he part of the
[__] suck Muk dick group yes he was
okay what the [__] s [__] that's a
good group white poly [__]
s sucky sucky group or whatever the [__]
it is I don't know nothing about this
[__] that's it Lee what the [__] you
they three stars you [__] yeah what are
you doing today tonight I'm doing
nothing because of this yes you are you
got to do something with your life
you're going to start Suns I already oh
yeah maybe I'll do that I I already went
to the gym today sure you did how how
long did you do one the thing an hour
and Jiu-Jitsu yesterday yeah jiujitsu
yesterday that was good it's I was
thinking on the drive over here how
every week I have the notebook with what
I'm going to write down and what I'm
going to do for the week and it's weird
that right before I get on the plane I
look at that sheat and I'm like [__] I
didn't do that and I didn't do that but
I did eight out of 10 Things I had on
that list just by writing
it maybe want to do it you know it's uh
it's crazy to this how it doesn't make
it it makes you feel good when you check
something off of a list if you're going
to work for
yourself
and you're going to be independent
contractor mhm you have to have some
type of schedule in your life so you
never
stale I can't ever even the other day I
was was in the house writing in that
[__] book and then I said let me
write com I went outside I smoked a
number and I sat in the sun and it was
two different worlds for me you know we
[__] vegetate too much that little
jiujitsu what is that an hour and a half
what do you got how many hours in a
week 7 time 20 [__] 4 then you divide
that by [__] 8 time so you need 56
hours so 160 right so you get 56 hours
of sleep you got $100 hours you ain't
got an hour and a half to go to
Jiu-Jitsu class you ain't got 5 hours to
put into a [__] College when you
break it down like that you'll be
embarrassed of your life what you really
do with your [__] life when you break
it into a Time stable so whatever 7 time
24 is how many hours a night you sleep
eight right 7 time 8 is what 56 so if it
this 160 and you minus 56 you still got
100 hours that means you got 100 hours
to play with all week you don't go to a
gym you don't take a class you don't do
something constructive for three or four
those hours a week there's something
wrong with your life right you really
got to look at it that way hourly wise I
don't care if you go learn Chinese
figures who gives a [__] at least you're
taking your mind off your miserable life
I mean that's the way I look at it and
that's why I go to jiu-ju because that
hour down an hour 45 minutes back
cutting people off and [__] at least it
takes my mind off writing a joke and you
know I got to get on the plane and I
beat myself up just like anybody else
you know you just to keep your mind
occupied especially when you're an
independent contractor at least if you
have a job for 40 hours you're doing
something for 40 hours that your mind is
somewhere else yeah five of those hours
you're going to FID it on the computer
and look at up porn and bang one out but
for the most part do you ever tell
someone to like check you or whatever
cuz I'm working on that seminar I'm
doing so I'm working on it and I told
Paula that she has to like check and see
like I made progress every week do you
ever do that or you just all self-
policed
cuz sometimes I need to know somebody's
going like get mad at me here's the
beauty of this that everybody thinks
that they're smart enough to control
everything and for years we all do that
until one day you realize you have
friends around you and these friends
care about you and they know you're
sense of humor and they also know what
you're trying to do they see the light
that's why you're friends with them as
crazy as I am I'm friends with John butt
today I went to hegan with John but you
know that right oh I didn't know you
went with yeah I went to John but with I
John but he's a good guy he's been nice
to me and uh what was I talking about
friends around you helping you yeah and
you have to ask two or three of your
friends for advice that know
you I came to you last week with a
problem about the special and I told you
what my numbers were and what my
parameters were and we both agreed on
them correct
yeah are you are you a comic
no but you have a different kind of mind
and and you know this so this is why I
come to you yeah you need you need
different points of view defit I go to
my wife who's shrewd as [__] and she
sees the green tape and she sees the
white tape cuz she's an accountant I
take my ideas to her so I take them to
the most intelligent people I know
pretty much and then I'll call a friend
from Jersey who I trust his judgment
I'll call one of them so now I have
three judgments in my judgment out of
those four judgments something's got to
be right you follow me yeah because I've
had the same formula for [__] years
with my life
I've always asked people that I trust
their judgment that'll say to me you
know what I like you I'll miss you if
you're gone but you can't stay here
you're going to die from doing drugs or
somebody's going to shoot you cuz
they're going to catch you robbing their
drugs so you need friends like that that
are honest with you you know yeah I was
watching James Brown movie okay did you
watch that yeah when he goes to the
guy's office and he wants to do a live
production it's a big fat Jew yeah yeah
and he goes yeah but it doesn't sell and
all a sudden he takes his shoes off and
and the Jew gets up and he starts
dancing and he goes what the hell are
you doing he goes I'm doing a mashed
potato he goes I don't do it right right
he goes that's right that's not my part
of the business I know the business side
of music so you take you should know how
to do the mashed potato and I'll take
care of the business side do you f me so
I don't know everything about everything
so I have to ask
questions right and I'm not going to ask
an agent cuz they're [__] greedy and
stupid you know they're not going to
give you their real advice they're going
to give you an advice from monetary
sense of how much are we going to make
on this right so I got to go two people
who care so that's how I make my
decisions though as of the moment I'll
call Rogan I'll call Ari you know and
you you make a joint [__] decision
somebody's going to come up with their
own answer and all help out to the cause
what's with the questions Co I know man
let's wrap it up here let's give a shout
out to the sponsors what do you got
going on this weekend anyway talk to me
we're going to San Francisco okay when
are you leaving Tom tomorrow morning
Friday morning Friday morning and what
time you leaving uh we're actually
thinking about leaving at like 600 to be
honest just to get up there probably
like around lunchtime cuz if we don't
leave at 6:00 we have to leave at like
11:00 cuz otherwise those we'll get
stuck in the morning traffic so you're
going to get stuck anywhere but not
North not too bad yeah it's not that bad
and then we're we're just we like to eat
so we looked at up a couple places to go
eat we're going to go to that hate
Ashbury part of town gonna go get some
clam chowder it's gonna be fun two years
good for you congratulations brother you
come a long way on the show you know
thank you buddy I see you were like
Rocky's wife when I met you all [__]
a little bit look at you got a pep to
your step you're putting down three
stars of Deb you're slinging dick and
Frisco like [__] clise wouldn't
Escape from
Alcatraz and you're taking it to the
next [__] level you know what
I'm saying well it's crazy for you too I
mean you just went on Rogan yesterday
right and just think just what we were
talking about earlier like look what
what did you think was going to happen
one of those first Rogan ones you were
on on either the couch when they were
sitting just in in uh these kind of
chairs I mean how cool was that for you
two guys do you ever guys just talk
about that like how you're sitting in in
front of like a thousand or so podcasts
of just you guys's just your own podcast
not the hundreds of other ones you've
done and it's just it's as much of a
part of you as being a comedian now like
four or five years later like I told you
before Lee if you think when I was in
that apartment in Bal I was thinking
about podcasting or being on the Johnny
Carson show or on Late Night with the
late Dave
Letterman I had
no nothing I knew nothing about this bro
you know this was I used to [__]
giggle at Rog when he first did it at
night I us said I'm not going over that
really I'm not going over and I was
cleaning sober then I was just smoking
dope I'm I'm like I'm not going over
there I'm not going over there and uh
look look what happened and Corolla and
Mark Marin [__] tremendous lineup at
the store last night Le just enough to
scare the pants off you really and I
can't lie to you Le I got a little
[__] anxiety again God damn it not
nowhere
[Music]
near last week nowhere near last week do
you think you were just nervous about it
because of last week and now it was
packed and I have no no idea what I
[__] said I just had a great time on
stage and I guess that's the [__]
bottom line it's just to have a great
time on stage and be loose like Tony in
[__]
84 anyway you want to be loose you got
to have good underwear you understand me
that's when me undies come in the
[__] quality the the craftsmanship
the way they fit how comfortable they
are oh my [__] God and you know what
I don't wear them with jeans just
because the Jeans cover everything I'm
going from point A to point B but if I'm
doing Jiu-Jitsu some athletic I put my
Mees on the nuts stay intact not too
much sweat keeps everything dry and you
know what man go to meundies.com look at
all the [__] selections they got of
men's and women's underwear t-shirts cut
off sweats long sweats they got some
cool ass [__] man go over to me on these
take a look you know I'm not messing
with you but El you got anything else to
say about me on this I got talk and and
you're right dude especially if you d to
if you don't have right the right
underwear on you're going to have to
readjust anything if you don't do
anything you have to readjust if you're
on a bike at the gym and you're trying
to warm up and you're pedaling your nut
always pops out of your left side or
your right side [__] that meundies go to
meundies.com right now and press in Joey
and get 20% off in Canada and the United
States but I had no idea girls didn't
don't like when you scratch like I I we
were out the other night the other week
and I was doing it at like just outside
of the bench and Paul looked at like I
was crazy yeah women don't like nobody
likes when you women will never scratch
or nothing in public that's why you got
to give them credit we're the only
animals that we have an it you only
control it we're not going to get up and
go all the way to the [__] bathroom
to pull a nut out sometimes a nut gets
tucked in by mistake you have that and
you're sitting there you're not in pain
sometimes I'm uncircumcised the
turleneck gets caught sometimes I got to
sit there with it talk then and have a
conversation with somebody how you think
I feel like that but anyway where does
it get caught right inside the
turtleneck like the skin and the
helmet's halfway like a little sausage
and it gets caught and it feels weird
when
you anyway go to meundies.com right now
and press in Jo and get a great
selection of underwear for men women
sexy women stuff I'm telling you this is
the bung big I wouldn't be [__] let
you [__] know how good meundies
were they a they weren't that good what
are they
pressing Joey and 20% off and free
delivery but was bom big bomb bity
that's what I meant to say a little
cotton mouth it's like I've been in
bafra all [__]
night on it tremendous you know why I
ate these Edibles cuz I pop this Alpha
Brain like they going out of [__]
style you understand me I go on Alpha
Brain Cycles you're like Joey what's
Alpha Brain you told me about it last
week I'll tell you it's a complete Earth
grown nut Tropic with Alpha GPC and
ac-11 don't ask me what it is go on
[__] the computer and you'll see how
good this stuff is you know how good it
is they give you 100% money back
guarantee and they don't even want the
product back That's How Strong [__]
on it is okay this starts with Alpha
Brain this is like the pork fried rice
of dead products if this is nothing why
would you go anywhere else start with
this right here alpab brain if not get
the hemp protein I love that stuff with
a little banana in there couple ice
cubes bam some peanut butter the best
chocolate tasting protein out in the
market number three the the The Chronic
what is it the the the the stuff for
your lungs the the mushrooms I can't
remember oh shro tech shro tech and
shroom Tech sport tremendous pre-workout
type stuff I'm telling you just do do me
a favor go to hit.com they'll give you
descriptions AR's doing a great job go
to h.com right now good look at the
great selection of supplements they got
battle ropes they got kettle bells I
can't do nothing for you there I can
only help you on the supplement whether
it's the MCT oil or the the testosterone
Bo listen go to honor right now and
press in church boom and get 10% off
your first order they also have to stay
on a program I mean they're all over the
computer start change your life today
start on it right
now you're like but J but what type of
snacks you got you got any little stars
at that that can't [__] help you you
live in Ohio I can't [__] help you
but I tell you what I will get you I'll
get you some snacks nutritious delicious
snacks nutritionist approve you don't
have to eat [__] garbage no more you
don't have to eat [__] processed [__]
this is tremendous snacks you understand
me whether it's the chocolate Nom Noms
whether it's those [__] French
toast pretzels they got some stuff
that's revolutionary all way don't make
me talk about the sarashi cashews don't
make me talk about what else Le don't
make me talk about what else the
chocolate num Noms the the corn kernels
like the corn kernels the cocoa almonds
listen every day they're adding new
stuff over there whether it's the
plantains from the South Pacific or the
garlic plantains every week they're
adding [__] that you go godamn damn this
stuff is great you know what I'm going
to do I'm going to give you a sample box
on the arm Grace for free cuz that's how
I roll you understand me free on the arm
five bags two big ones three little ones
take a look at the srra cashews take a
look at the Chate Nom Noms and second a
look what else they got on there you're
going to find five bags you're going to
love and after that don't [__] don't
even email me and thank me that's how
good this stuff is but all starts with
you go to naturebox.com right now pick
out five items and what are they going
what they
/jy Joey and you get a [__] free
naturebox.com sample box five bags
delivered straight to your house Grace
you going have to pay for delivery
charges with a buck 90 leave if you're
lucky you know stop complaining all
right they're giving you two free nights
of snacks while you there smoking dope
for free and now you want to complain
about a little $1.90 you cheap [__]
anyway go to naturebox.com right now and
press in naturebox.com Joey boom and
there you have it but H don't go nowhere
couple weeks ago
I got a little box and Blue Apron I
cooked up both meals and I retweeted the
pictures just to show you between you
and me you guys know I'm half [__]
you do know that I'm [__] up I can't
cook my wife had to help me but I did it
and I did it because uh that's how I
roll all right I wanted to really give
Blue Apron a try before I gave I busted
you people's balls let me tell you what
Blue Apron does they deliver farm fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes you
could be a [__] complete homo they
delivered it right to your home allowing
you to create handcraft meals at your
home without going to the [__]
grocery store these [__] products
refreshing there I'm not busing your
balls the lemons and they deliver
everything like if they deliver a fish
dish they they'll come with two lemons
to the pepper to put it everything now
this is for less than 10 bucks the meal
Blue Apron will send you the ingredients
perfectly proportionate making cooking
[__] healthy meals easy as [__] no
trips to the grocer fre store because
you forgot this no one used this now I
got nothing everything is to the [__]
dot Blue Apron is perfect for dat night
let's say you meet a chick you want to
impress her you bring her over you tell
her yourself you're a half a [__] but
you can still make a little [__] Blue
Apron dick it's perfect for cooking with
friends and even family PL let's say
you're [__] divorced and you're a
loser and the kid comes over the to
spend the night you could impress them
they got kid-friendly ingredients to the
whole family can eat well and you and
you have fun preparing the meals
together each meal is 500 calories 5 to
700 I'm sorry for serving and it's
[__] tasty the two meals I had two
weeks ago were tremendous the fish and
the steak whatever it was tat tremendous
and this's what they got this week all
right flat iron steak Romano bean and
barley risoto are you [__] kidding me
or what stir fried sesan eggplant who's
ever [__] done nothing like that you
know who Blue Apron but don't take it
from me all right do me a favor we're
going to hook you up with two free meals
by going to Blue apron. no blueapron.com
joeey that's right blueapron.com joeey
my treat really the first two meals are
on me when you go to bl.com Joey all
right.com Joey so there you have it you
have on it meundies.com NatureBox and
Blue Apron I'm hooking you up with two
free [__] something somewhere along
the Box don't bother me no more all
right who hooks you up with nothing at
least you take an ear beat and you get
something for free right or wrong if
you're going to take the ear beating
from Uncle Joey from [__] Lisi at you
might as well get a nature box or a nice
Blue Apron two dinners on me all right
and that's it I'm going to Atlanta
[__] I love you guys with all my
heart thank you for another funfill week
here with myself and Lee say we're over
here trying to make your hour more
enjoyable man that's all we're trying to
do right [__] always all right
look at this poor bastard I just love
the idea hey you're divorced you're
living in a small apartment your life's
over I've been there blue apron I've
been there if I would have had Blue
Apron I would have been a [__] better
Dad I probably would have been there
right now not doing a
podcast jumping up and down with you
[__]
Babs you know I love you have a good
weekend I'll see you Monday afternoon
Monday night we got great great [__]
guest next week episode 300 next
Wednesday
2:00 300 episodes that's crazy 300
episodes people thank you for taking the
[__] crazy ride with us we'll see you
next week 5 a.m.